these days it is impossible to be
anonymous between Twitter YouTube
Instagram Facebook twitch and all the
other social media platforms on the
internet you can basically watch
someone's entire life from start to
finish in real time and that means that
certain public figures have become
mimetic celebrities with cults of
personality formed around them please
email me at gaben at valve software comm
and let me know about your rampage I'm
not wearing underwear okay but one
person has managed to become a celebrity
without losing their anonymity one
person has spent years in the shadows
but is still revered as a god
icefrog DotA's lead designer is the last
anonymous person on the internet but
after this video that won't be the case
you can't stop me
alright but I will save my grand reveal
for the end despite the fact that he's
been working on some version of dota for
nearly 15 years we basically know
nothing about icefrog
and that's exactly how he likes it we do
know a few things though iced frogs
either 35 or 36 he really likes cats and
has at least one named Nova
he loves mangoes and he speaks some
Chinese wait did I just read his tinder
bio uh he's single
icefrog got his start as a programmer on
dota all-stars in 2005 before having the
entire project effectively dumped in his
lap by the game's lead at the time a guy
by the name of Mike s see back in the
day
dota didn't really have a design team as
much as it had a bunch of teenagers and
college kids on forums throwing things
together and calling themselves devs
once icefrog took over the game became
significantly more balanced for
competitive play and was rapidly
appreciated for being both complex and
meticulously designed the issue is that
people weren't immediately satisfied in
fact some people were actually pissed at
ice frogs changes and thought they would
spell doom for dota but they were just
fools who couldn't understand his gene
[Music]
but despite the fact that he's been the
developer of one of the biggest games in
the eSports world for nearly two decades
icefrog has managed to remain entirely
off the grid and because of his
anonymity rumors are constantly
circulating about iced frogs true
identity it makes sense people always
want to know more about the people
crafting their favorite games but with
icefrog there was a time when figuring
out his true identity reached a fever
pitch back in 2010 a year after he was
hired by valve someone claiming to be a
valve employee wrote an angry blog post
alleging that icefrog was an [__]
[Music]
under the veil of anonymity they
basically doxed icefrog claiming to know
his real name where he lived and perhaps
most importantly saying he was an
antisocial jerk who was terrible to work
with I mean this guy was a real jerk at
the time people weren't sure what to
believe but as the years went on more
and more details were uncovered that
made it more believable specifically his
name and trust me will will get to his
name references to ice frogs name
appeared in that blog post and the same
name was referenced in a reddit post by
riot co-founder mark Tryndamere Merrill
along with the credits to the dota
documentary free to play however there
were still some dota fans out there who
didn't buy it
who knew there had to be another answer
that icefrog was actually infamous dota
weirdo Bruno I'm going to call the
spirits I don't know who I'm going to
get I might get period flags I might get
eyes from young drugs now Bruno
definitely isn't icefrog
but he did join valve in 2015 and I
don't think I've ever seen him a nice
frog in the same room at the same time
there was a time when ice frog wasn't
the insular hermit he is now back in the
day he would regularly post to the dota
all-stars forums and the play dota
website it's unclear exactly why he
stopped but there are allegations that
Western fans basically harassed him off
the blogs
icefrog then moved to pretty much
exclusively blogging in Chinese over on
Weibo but he slowed down his posting
there too these days making him an
international man of mystery once again
but here's the thing despite the fact
that so few people actually know who he
is
icefrog is borderline worshiped by dota
pros and fans alike what he's done well
he studies stuck to his way of looking
at the game and his way of looking at
heroes and and sometimes he doesn't
balance heroes in a certain way because
he wants that to be the definition of
the hero so he will always work around
balancing also connected to everything
that makes total special and everything
that makes the heroes special icefrog
is revered and it totally makes sense
why there's almost no one in gaming let
alone esports who's been solely
responsible for balancing a game for as
long as he has in fact icefrog style is
so distinguishable that some conspiracy
theorists think that DotA's recent
changes hint that he stopped working on
dota a while ago and now someone else is
in charge and sure that sounds extremely
tinfoil Hattie but also how would you
ever know almost no one knows who
icefrog
is or what he looks like he could have
been made up this whole time false
stories all made up lies lies the
closest comparison to icefrog is a guy
like Masahiro Sakurai who has been
designing the Smash Brothers series
since day one the difference is that
hardcore smash players tend to dislike
Sakurai's design choices since they tend
to take the game further and further
away from the competitive rules set the
community has designed meanwhile ice
frog's word is law nobody disagrees with
his decisions because they know he sees
things they never will he understands
the game
better than them dota isn't a team
project it's the [__] motorcycle in
ice frogs garage dota fans think of
icefrog
as their God which basically makes gaben
his Pope I guess icefrog singular vision
for dota made it one of the most
balanced competitive games ever which
has made a lot of people ask for the
same kind of figure in other games
imagine if csgo had a nice frog the
bones onto the map what the [__] are you
serious right now
bomb is under the mouth hey when the 8th
round for LAN finals the bomb has
glitched are you [__] me
I think Counter Strike global Offensive
needs someone like this or it would be
ideal if we could have someone like this
but icefrog doesn't actually craft dota
all by himself there's obviously a team
working on the game but icefrog
allegedly does all the balancing work
himself right well that's not exactly
true
see icefrog is known for asking pros
what they think of his planned changes
and I think the nice thing about him was
always that he made an effort to ask
people the word top of the game you know
to get them involved from day one and
that's wild that there's this secret
inner circle that gets to influence the
decisions of one of gaming's only oh
tours which means your best ticket into
the amphibian Illuminati
is to become a dota god of course that
doesn't mean that the only way to meet
icefrog is to become the best Jodha
player in the world all you have to do
is go to TI since there's a pretty good
chance that he's there too if you've
been to TI there's a pretty good chance
that you've seen icefrog the guy's been
known to show up incognito which means
he's probably sitting in the stands with
everyone else
you couldn't even had a conversation
with icefrog and not even realized it I
met the man I met him
it's likely the second time I met him
but the first time I didn't realize this
if he didn't introduce himself as the
man so that was cool I got to meet him
she goes no I'm talking about right you
might be thinking why does he do this
why does icefrog go to TI and risk
getting his veil of anonymity lifted
just to watch a couple of games that he
could see from a VIP room or even at
home on Twitch well despite working on
the game for longer than some of its
players have been alive icefrog still
loves dota just as much as the fans do
that's why he's their God that's why
they have a complicated unspoken social
contract to never reveal his true
identity because he cares about dota
just like they do and maybe even more
than any of us could understand but I
haven't signed that contract dota is for
suckers and I am here to reveal ice
frogs true identity icefrog is Z trees
can't do this it's too dangerous
yeah what's he gonna do to me oh god oh
god oh god oh god I don't know ever
gonna make it out of here alive the
information it needs to get out there
iced frogs real name is
I mean estimate some place let's go
hardcore for the last month I have often
wondered this question
[Music]
so my girlfriend's my different hates
counter-strike and she that you like
spicy